[Música]
la Corte Internacional de Justicia Se
declaró competente para fallar en la
disputa fronteriza entre Venezuela y
Guyana sobre el equipo mientras Guyana
celebró la noticia Caracas no reconoció
el papel del supremo tribunal de
la ONU el presidente de Chile Gabriel
borich promulgó un paquete de nuevas
leyes sobre seguridad que incluye una
polémica Norma para proteger
jurídicamente a los policías que usen
sus armas de fuego en defensa propia
tenemos detalles desde Santiago
la Casa Blanca culpa principalmente al
gobierno de Donald Trump por las fallas
que hubo durante La retirada de
Afganistán cuando los talibanes Se
tomaron el poder sin que las tropas
estadounidenses hubieran salido en su
totalidad la administración de Joe biden
publicó un resumen al respecto con
reportes de inteligencia de 2021
Bienvenidos a las noticias que France 24
dedica a América yo soy María Clara
calle
iniciamos con la actualidad de la Corte
Internacional de Justicia que se declaró
competente para determinar qué pasa en
la histórica disputa entre Venezuela y
Guyana sobre el territorio de
ezequivo Caracas argumentaba que el
máximo tribunal de la ONU no podía
interceder sin que Reino Unido
participara Pues fue el colonizador de
Guyana cuando la pelea fronteriza
comenzó en 1899 sin embargo la corte
rechazó el alegato y comenzará la
audiencia Rafael Pérez nos explica
un desacuerdo territorial con más de un
siglo de existencia continúa sobre la
mesa de la justicia internacional el
máximo órgano judicial de las Naciones
Unidas Se declaró que un jurisdicción en
el diferendo limítrofe que sostienen
Venezuela y Guyana el espacio en disputa
es abundante en petróleo gas y otros
minerales representa el 70% del
territorio cuyanés Georgetown aplaudió
el anuncio
todos los estados miembros de las
Naciones Unidas incluidos Guyana y
Venezuela están obligados en virtud de
la carta de las Naciones Unidas a
cumplir con las sentencias vinculantes
de la corte sin embargo Venezuela no
reconoce el rol de la Corte
Internacional de Justicia que la
República bolivariana de Venezuela no
reconoce el mecanismo judicial como
medio de resolución de la mencionada
controversia por cuanto excluye la
naturaleza y objeto de este acuerdo
Rodríguez se refiere al pacto firmado
con el Reino Unido en 1966 que establece
los a seguir para la resolución del
conflicto Caracas arguye que la
discusión es con el reino inglés
Seguiremos la lucha incansable y firme
por defender el respeto al histórico
acuerdo de Ginebra y la territorialidad
de nuestra digna nación
Guyana que en la década de los 60 no
había alcanzado su independencia de
Londres rechaces argumento sobre una
sentencia de 1899 que ya había
establecido los límites actuales el
origen del caso en la corte mundial Data
de 2018 cuando una representación
guyanesa pidió el alto tribunal que
ratificara los bordes establecidos en
París
el presidente de Chile Gabriel borich
promulgó un paquete de nuevas leyes
sobre seguridad que incluye en una
polémica Norma para proteger
jurídicamente a los carabineros que usen
sus armas de fuego en defensa propia
todo en un contexto en el que en menos
de un mes han matado a tres policías
también hay otras iniciativas para
Elevar las penas de algunos delitos y
tipificar la extorsión nuestra
corresponsal Patricia Luna Nos daba
previamente los detalles
jornada de conmoción y luto en la que se
vive en Chile tras el asesinato de
Tercer policía en 23 días Lo que hablaba
una crisis de inseguridad que se vive en
el país y que constituye la primera
preocupación de los chilenos y también
una de las preocupaciones fundamentales
del gobierno de Gabriel borich borich
acudió al funeral de este policía en el
que se vivieron momentos de mucha
conmoción como cuando se acercó a
contener a una vida desconsolada y al
que también acudieron varios
expresidentes de la historia reciente
del país como la expresidenta Michelle
bachelet y los expresidentes
y Ricardo lagos entre otras autoridades
tras eso se dirigió al palacio de la
moneda y realizó una serie un discurso
lo hizo rodeado de varios de sus
ministros más importantes todos vestidos
de luto riguroso con el gesto muy
contenido en el que se anunciaron una
serie de medidas como el incremento de
1500 millones de dólares anuales para
comprar un mayor equipamiento para la
que las policías puedan realizar su
trabajo y también para mejorar los
procesos de investigación y los procesos
judiciales en torno a los delitos además
anunció la puesta en marcha del plan
calle sin violencia y afirmó que seguirá
trabajando para garantizar la Seguridad
Ciudadana pero también social y
económica de todos los chilenos eso
entre otra serie de medidas en una
jornada en la que además el presidente
promulgó de manera Express La polémica
al rey ley naín retamal que modifica el
uso de las armas por parte de las
policías en los casos de legítima
defensa pero también promulgó otras tres
nuevas leyes una que tipifica el delito
de extorsión y otras dos leyes que
agravan las penas en caso de secuestro y
también en caso deporte de armas en
lugares muy congregados
el jueves fue un día de luto en Brasil
en diferentes cementerios hicieron los
funerales de los cuatro menores de edad
que fueron asesinados en un ataque con
hacha Ellos tenían Entre cuatro y siete
años la ciudad de blumeo en el estado de
Santa Catarina se despidió de los niños
Mientras que el principal sospechoso
estaba bajo custodia policial El joven
de 25 años se entregó a las autoridades
presuntamente después de haber irrumpido
en la guardería cantiño Don pastor el
miércoles y matar supuestamente a los
menores el presidente Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva dijo que su gobierno tardará 90
días en elaborar la propuesta de la
política nacional para enfrentar la
violencia en las escuelas
administración del presidente Joe biden
publicó un resumen de los informes
clasificados sobre cómo fue la retirada
de Estados Unidos en Afganistán el
reporte de doce páginas culpa
principalmente al gobierno de Donald
Trump Pues según los análisis de mayo de
2021 el departamento de estado y el
pentágono estimaban que los talibanes
podrían tomarse el poder a finales de
ese año y después de que las tropas
estadounidenses salieran pero realmente
se apoderaron del país en agosto los
republicanos criticaron que bailen
culpara a Trump así se pronunció la casa
blanca
si bien siempre fue la intención del
presidente poner fin a esa guerra
también es innegable que las decisiones
tomadas y la falta de planificación de
la Administración anterior limitaron
significativamente las opciones
disponibles para él El presidente biden
heredó una presencia militar en
Afganistán de unos 2500 soldados Esa fue
la más baja desde 2001 heredó un
programa especial de Visas de
inmigrantes que había de recursos y
heredó un acuerdo alcanzado entre la
administración anterior y los talibanes
que pedía la eliminación completa de
todas las tropas estadounidenses para
mayo de 2021 o de lo contrario los
talibanes que habían detenido sus
ataques mientras había un acuerdo
volverían a la guerra en contra de
Estados Unidos
luego de las restricciones Durante los
años de pandemia Centroamérica vuelve a
vivir con intensidad la celebraciones de
Semana Santa la procesión religiosa más
concurrida ocurre en antigua Guatemala a
la que asisten cientos de miles de
personas muchos de ellos viajan desde
otros países como El Salvador Honduras y
Nicaragua nuestros corresponsales Andrés
Suárez Jaramillo y Aurora bayud nos
traen la historia
en la víspera de la procesión religiosa
que más fieles Católicos congrega en
Centroamérica Carlos Martínez apenas
tendrá una hora para dormir Guatemala es
el corazón de la fe de la religiosidad
Popular
siendo un feligrés salvadoreño Carlos
viajó hasta antigua Guatemala para
personificar a uno de los romanos de la
centuria
y estamos listos
su misión es la de marchar por más de 20
horas ininterrumpidas encarnando al
centurión que en la Biblia le pide a
Jesús curar a uno de sus criados es lo
que él vino a hacer es la enseñanza que
Jesús que Jesús se hizo hombre verdad
habitó entre nosotros nos enseñó a
perdonar
cerca de 300.000 personas entre fieles y
curiosos acuden a admirar la escultura
consagrada de Jesús Nazareno de la caída
Pedro Pablo rives feligreses de la
hermandad Santa Lucía asiste a estas
procesiones desde hace 12 años por
devoción recordemos que somos la semana
santa la Jerusalén de Centroamérica y de
América tenemos imágenes que nos
representan de más de 300 años imágenes
que ya están consagradas acá en la
Guatemala en antigua ciudad patrimonio
cultural de la humanidad durante la
semana santa la ocupación hotelera es de
más del 90% tras enterarse de las
procesiones a través de un documental
Jessica y su esposo viajaron desde Malta
para vivir de cerca la experiencia
[Música]
es muy bonito hay muchas procesiones
muchas estatuas 60 personas cargando
este Jesús lo estamos disfrutando mucho
el instituto de turismo de Guatemala
Calcula que los ingresos turísticos por
la semana santa podrían sobrepasar los
345 millones de dólares un crecimiento
del 20% con respecto a la semana santa
de 2022 y una recuperación del 95% con
relación a la del 2019
[Música]
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con 24